الرئاسه الروسيه تعرض لمحاوله هجوم
بطائرات مسيره اوكرانيه وفق ما اعلنت
موسكو
الكرملين كلمه تعني القلعه التي تحمي مركز
المدينه واهم الادارات فيها كل المدن
التاريخيه الروسيه تحتوي على كرملين خاص
بها المبنى ذو القبه الذي تابعنا لقطات له
هو مجلس شيوخ الكرملين الذي يطل على
الساحه الحمراء وهو اداره تابعه لرئاسه
الروسيه ويبعد قرابه 500 متر عن القصر
الرئاسي تابعنا لقطات الانفجار وكما اعلنت
موسكو فقد تم تعطيله وتفجير الطائرتين
المسيرتين بواسطه الدفاعات الالكترونيه في
الكرملين دون حدوث اضرار ماديه او بشريه
روسيا لم تعلن اي تفاصيل الا ان التحليلات
تشير الى ان الهجوم نفذ بواسطه مسيرات
تجاريه اطلقت من مسافه غير بعيده من شارع
مخوفايا غرب الكرملين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات